[Music]
the future prosperity of Europe depends
on our capacity to adapt to key
challenges such as climate change and
the digitalization of our economies
and we all agree that full fiber
networks provide the only future-proof
and sustainable solution
today over 50 percent of European
citizens have access to fiber but while
much progress has been made there are
still many hurdles to overcome
in most countries rural regions are
still poorly served by fiber and it is
vital that we push for ubiquitous
rollouts to avoid creating new digital
divides
in-home connectivity becomes
increasingly important as Wi-Fi is the
natural extension of fiber and needs to
keep Pace with higher levels of fiber
performance
[Music]
take up rates in many countries are too
low and significant efforts are required
to convince greater numbers of
subscribers to adopt fiber
decommissioning of Legacy copper
networks is the ultimate step towards
full fiber migration bringing great
Savings in energy consumption and
reducing carbon emissions completion of
ftth rollout requires significant
funding and relies on public authorities
setting the right conditions to
encourage investment in full fiber
networks and increase adoption by
citizens and businesses in Europe
[Music]
the ftt age conference is the world's
largest fiber Summit designed to address
these challenges and facilitate exchange
between key stakeholders
technology vendors service providers
operators investors regulators and
policy makers together we are creating
the conditions for insightful discussion
fruitful networking and profitable
collaboration
welcome to the ftth conference 2023
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]